hey welcome everybody um one of the
things we're going to spend some time
talking about today are the recent
protests
and unrest and violence and the way that
uh people have been trying to take
advantage of that violence and unrest
but before we even do that one of the
things i want to talk about is this
broader context
in which donald trump is running for
president
as if someone else has been president
for the last
four years and that's just one
aspect of what i want to focus in on
today and and that particular aspect is
really unlike anything we've seen
um in the modern political era for
presidents running for re-election most
presidents have run for re-election
very clearly on i've been in charge for
four years
and we're going to get another four
years that will be similar to the last
four
and that's good donald trump is doing
something very very different and that's
what i want to talk about now before we
get we get into that i guess it's
important to mention
i'm leaving a lot out of this analysis
uh
in terms of things that donald trump is
doing of course this has been one of the
most dishonest presidencies the lie
count is off the charts and donald trump
has been doing a lot of lying
to justify his re-election as well okay
on the
issues donald trump has failed to
deliver on a bunch of different campaign
issues
the wall replacing the health care
system on and on and on
but there's a reason that i want to
focus in on this particular aspect
because it relates to
the sort of gaslighty nature
of the campaign as well as the
um intellectually compromised element of
donald trump's electorate
which is that donald trump is framing
his re-election campaign as if you need
to choose him
instead of what we've had for the last
four years and unfortunately it's
working on a lot of people as evidenced
by some of the interviews when you go to
these rallies that donald trump has been
doing
the rnc etc and the language that trump
is using suggests somebody else has
been in charge for the last four years
and in order to
fix that donald trump must be elected
when you look at this phrase make
america great again
again that is predicated
on the implicit understanding that trump
won in 2016 and for a while he was great
and he made america great again
and then that sort of fell apart
including with coronavirus
and the economy and now we need to elect
trump in order to make america great
again again because it's almost like
trump hasn't been the one in charge for
the last six or seven months
we have to put trump back in power to
fix problems
that were actually created during donald
trump's presidency
as if he was not in charge during that
time this
is going to be a big factor in our
discussion about
protests and unrest donald trump
has been talking about the mass protests
and the unrest
with the framing of democrat cities as
he says
run by far-left mayors anarchists or
anarchists
as he calls them marxists and others the
reality
is that it's trump himself who has
generated the unrest
we didn't have unrest like this when joe
biden was vice president for eight years
and i'm going to come back to that in a
little bit
there's been donald trump's mishandling
of so many issues
but trump is running as if other people
have been in charge for the last six
months
and in order to get things back under
control
you need to elect donald trump now of
course any thinking person would realize
trump is saying things are out of
control with me as president
so re-elect me to fix it but
of course why would we do that why
wouldn't trump
just be able to get things under control
now in other words why is he
saying that only in his second term will
he be able to get these things under
control and of course when you realize
that he's been what's been generating
the unrest and the discontent
the entire argument falls apart in in
some sense
trump is almost running against himself
but
putting in joe biden as a proxy to take
the hit
for donald trump's own failings and i i
wish it weren't
the case there's really no way to say
this without offending some people
but his supporters that are eating it up
are eating it up in great part because
they are intellectually compromised now
some of them know it's bs
but they want trump re-elected for other
reasons and so they're just jumping on
the bandwagon but a lot of people are
actually falling for this stuff
now there's a few different thoughts
about why donald trump
is doing this one thought is that this
is some kind of four-dimensional chess
he's taking credit for successes but
painting the failings on joe biden or on
democratic mayors or whoever the case
may be and it's all
kind of uh calculated to paint him
as the underdog despite the fact that
he's the incumbent right we could go
into some kind of more complex
analysis the other explanation is way
simpler which is trump's a one-trick
pony
he doesn't know how to run as the
incumbent
and he is running the exact same
campaign
that he ran as the supposed political
outsider in 2016
he's just running the same campaign
ignoring the fact that he's been the
president for four years
we really have not seen anything like
this and it's preying upon
the most ignorant voters but that is not
a guarantee that it's going to fail to
work it very well
could succeed and this is why i've been
sounding the alarm now for several weeks
saying
we can't write off what to many of us
seem like
obviously terrible strategies as
ineffective
because it may work donald trump
genuinely expects that americans are
going to fall for this
and plenty of americans are falling for
it now
the other thing on top of this which we
have to remember
is that joe biden was sort of in charge
for eight years in other words when joe
biden was vice president
okay barack obama was the president but
we didn't have in obama and biden's
america
chaos and unrest the likes of which
donald trump is now preemptively
assigning to joe biden you had tea
partiers
who sometimes protested uh you you had
ferguson which was a
very different thing than what we have
going on right now you certainly had
shootings but that was a gun problem
which we have not fixed
but things were actually far more calm
during the era
in which joe biden was vice president to
the president of the united states
and so at even on the facts
you don't even have to hypothesize what
it would be like
if joe biden were president you can go
back and see what things were like when
joe biden was vice president and we're
going to get
into later on in the program why
is it that trump benefits from chaos
and unrest you would think that if
people
were thinking clearly they would say oh
if there's chaos and unrest
while trump is president doesn't make
sense to vote for him again
to fix it we should vote for someone
else that would be a logical assessment
i'm going to explain to you later on in
the program
uh why why that doesn't work or in other
words why
donald trump does benefit from the chaos
and why he's trying to incite it but
before we go to that let's talk about
the after effects of the republican
national convention